wieder eine kehrtwende in thüringen
thomas kemmerich räumt jetzt doch sofort
den posten des ministerpräsidenten
orkantief trifft deutschland ab morgen
bringt sabine windböen von bis zu 140
kilometern pro stunde
die deutsche bahn rät von zugreisen ab
mit riesenvorsprung zum heimsieg
viktoria rebensburg gewinnt die weltcup
abfahrt von garmisch partenkirchen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend bekommen an
diesem 8 februar einem ereignisreichen
samstag in einer politisch brisanten
woche mit ausführlichem sport und
norbert könig erfreuliches auch noch vom
skispringen schönen guten abend und
wieder kommt die nachricht des tages aus
thüringen wo der seit mittwoch amtieren
der fdp ministerpräsident kemmerich nun
überraschend doch schon heute und mit
sofortiger wirkung zurückgetreten ist
damit zieht er die konsequenzen aus
seiner umstrittenen wahl die nur mit
hilfe der afg zustande gekommen war
offenbar war der druck aus berlin wo sie
am nachmittag die spitzen der koalition
trafen zu groß geworden
hagen nicolas und matthias kubica aus
erfurt die kemmerich tritt zurück
tag 3 mit druck von der straße ein paar
hundert demonstranten am vormittag in
gera am nachmittag per tweet lässt
kemmerich seien mit afd stimmen gewonnen
es am tatsächlich los ich habe soeben
einen rücktritt als ministerpräsident
des freistaates thüringen mit sofortiger
wirkung erklärt ein polit-drama
ohnegleichen erst der von der afg
aufgestellte schein kandidat die cdu die
sich bei kemmerich nicht enthält sein
sieg und der anschlag mit bio ecke 24
stunden später der angekündigte
rücktritt jetzt plötzlich mit sofortiger
wirkung die cdu einsilbig das nehmen wir
zur kenntnis und dass es ausschließlich
angelegenheit der fdp deutschland und
der fdp thüringen dass ein längst
überfälliger schritt nach jetzt hagen
der romanreihe von cambridge nach themen
am betrug hier wirklich dieser tsunami
losgebrochen ist die spd fordert dass es
sofort neuwahlen gibt neuwahlen deshalb
weil die wählerinnen und wähler am 27
oktober letzten jahres unter ganz
anderen voraussetzungen gewählt haben
der schritt ist konsequent aber längst
überfällig und er zeigt vor allen dingen
auch das kemmerich taktiert hat seit
mittwoch es gab nie einen rechtlichen
grund der ihnen gehindert hat daran
sofort zurückzutreten
die afg gibt sich verwundert über den
schlingerkurs thomas kemmerich und bodo
ramelow lässt wissen er stehe für die
wahl zum ministerpräsidenten
bereit ja das war nun wirklich einen
zick zack kurs von thomas kemmerich
frage also in unsere korrespondentin
melanie haack in erfurt wie geht es denn
da jetzt nach dem rücktritt weiter ja
also zunächst muss man sagen dass ich
hier erst mal alle sammeln mussten weil
die nachricht ja wirklich hier alle
überrascht hat und gleichzeitig viele
auch erleichtert hat weiter geht es so
dass thomas kemmerich als
ministerpräsident geschäftsführend im
amt bleibt denn das land braucht ja
einen ministerpräsidenten
gleichzeitig aber ist er quasi
handlungsunfähig er darf beispielsweise
keine minister ernennen
er hat also keine möglichkeiten mehr
könnte auch keine vertrauensfrage
stellen
damit ist jetzt der weg frei für eine
sondersitzung des landtages da gibt es
eine ladungsfrist von sieben tagen das
heißt diese sondersitzung könnte
frühestens am 17
februar stattfinden und dann käme es
dort wieder zur neuwahl eines
ministerpräsidenten wie diese wahl
ausgeht und ob es danach doch noch
neuwahlen gibt das ist derzeit offen
die spd beispielsweise hatte ja eben
angekündigt wie gerade auch im stück
gehört sie wolle danach trotzdem neu
waren also nach wie vor und wieder mal
alles offen hier in thüringen bleibt
also aufregend vielen dank melanie haack
von thüringen nach berlin wo sich heute
wie schon gehört die spitzen der großen
koalition zusammen gesetzt haben kein
kein lange geplanter termin sondern ein
krisentreffen
dabei einigten sich cdu csu und spd auf
eine klare absage an die afd einzel eine
zusammenarbeit mit ihr dürfe es nicht
geben unter gar keinen umständen daniel
pontzen demo gegen rechts heute vor dem
kanzleramt wo ab 13 uhr der
koalitionsausschuss tagt
kurz davor hatte die spd-spitze per
interview noch einmal den druck erhöht
es entstehe eine zitat äußerst
schwierige situation für die groko
sollte die cdu nicht glaubhaft
versichern mir ein zusammenspiel mit der
afg künftig verhindert werden
gut zwei stunden später wurde genau dies
im ergebnis versichert zudem ließ es nun
erwarte man nach dem unverzeihlichen
vorgang der
umgehend ein neuer ministerpräsident im
landtag gewählt wird um den zu
legitimieren seien baldige neuwahlen
erforderlich die klarheit in unserer
position hat einen wesentlichen beitrag
dazu geleistet dass der
koalitionsausschuss ins gesamte
koalition zur stabilität der demokratie
in unserem land wichtiges beigetragen
hat wir müssen aber genauso gut sagen
dass auch die kanzlerin und die seite
der cdu und der csu sich dieser an sich
nicht widersetzt oder nicht verschlossen
hat man habe auch kontakt mit christian
lindner gehabt die fdp habe die position
mitgetragen wenig später erfolgte
kemmerich rücktritt schon am vormittag
musste er zurücktreten als ost
beauftragter der bundesregierung
christian hirte cdu
er hatte die wahl kammerichs am mittwoch
gelobt die spd daraufhin seine
entlassung gefordert den die kanzlerin
nun erbat alles wieder gut also nein
sagt die linke die diese woche als zäsur
wertet die elendige gleichsetzung von
links und rechts die gleichsetzung von
rot und braun und vergleiche zwischen
bodo ramelow und jemandem wie hocke
das ist der nährboden auf dem das alles
gewachsen ist von politischem brand war
diese woche viel die rede
der brandherd scheint nun halbwegs unter
kontrolle die löscharbeiten aber dauern
an
ja frage an chuck und annabella dzi in
berlin wie steht es denn nun um die
groko und welches signal sendet sie
heute nach thüringen aus also für heute
ist der ganz große streit hier in der
großen koalition erst einmal vom tisch
wir haben es gehört es gab diese
gemeinsame erklärung die ist hier auch
in ruhiger atmosphäre erarbeitet worden
hören wir aus den parteikreisen
und das signal an thüringen ist ganz
klar klare kante gegen die afg im
nächsten anlauf das problem an der
ganzen sache ist nur dass es diese
ansage aus der cdu eigentlich vorher
auch schon gegeben hat es gab einen
parteitagsbeschluss es gab einen
beschluss des parteivorstandes und das
ergebnis das kennen wir und es gibt für
den nächsten anlauf eben keine absolute
garantie dass es jetzt so kommt wie sich
die berliner parteispitze das gerne
wünschen würde und wir haben heute hier
gesehen dass die parteispitze um max
die male schadensbegrenzung bemüht ist
ein problem bleibt allerdings die cdu
hat nur auf dem papier ein klares
verhältnis zur afg und übrigens auch zur
linken
ob das dann wieder aufbricht wenn der
nächste versuch nicht ganz so läuft wie
sich das alle vorstellen das werden wir
sehen
danke für ihre analyse aktueller berlin
zum anderen großen thema der woche dem
corona virus wieder fliegt deutschland
bundesbürger aus der chinesischen
millionenstadt wochen aus morgen soll
ein flugzeug mit 20 rückkehrern aus der
besonders stark betroffenen region in
berlin landen
sie sollen dann für mindestens zwei
wochen in quarantäne bleiben
aus frankreich werden heute neue corona
fälle gemeldet fünf briten haben sich im
urlaub in den alpen angesteckt und
werden im krankenhaus in lyon behandelt
nach angaben der französischen
gesundheitsministerin ist aber keiner
der patienten lebensgefährlich erkrankt
seit sich corona auch jenseits von china
ausbreitet gibt es auch diese
befürchtung was wenn das virus sich in
ländern mit schwachen gesundheitssystem
festsetzt in afrika etwa wann wäre die
lungenkrankheit nur noch schwer
einzudämmen glauben fachleute der
kontinent scheint aus mehreren gründen
besonders gefährdet tim kröger ein
viertel in der äthiopischen hauptstadt
addis abeba
hier entwickelt sich langsam ein kleines
china town mehr als eine million
chinesen sollen bereits in afrika lieben
zigtausende junge afrikaner studieren in
der volksrepublik china ist afrikas
größter handelspartner
experten halten deswegen ein
übergreifendes corona virus auf
afrikanische staaten für durchaus
möglich noch gibt es keinen bestätigten
teil viele länder aber bereiten sich auf
das virus vor kritisch ist vor allem
dass wir die fälle schnell nachweisen
bevor mehr menschen angesteckt werden
denn eine hohe zahl von infizierten wäre
schwierig zu kontrollieren mit den
gesundheitssystemen die wir in vielen
ländern afrikas haben
längst gibt es reisewarnungen mehrere
ricanische fluggesellschaften haben ihre
verbindungen nach china ausgesetzt noch
in diesem monat so die bh afrika sollen
36 staaten mit testmöglichkeiten
ausgestattet sein
einigen ländern helfe es der sie sich
bereits während der ebola ausbrüche mit
maßnahmen wie flughafenkontrollen
isolationsstation und behandlungszentren
vorbereitet haben sagt michael jung von
der whu afrika das sind gute
voraussetzungen auf denen man aufbauen
kann für das corona virus einige länder
fangen nicht bei null an aber es sei
noch viel zu tun damit die afrikanischen
länder auf das virus vorbereitet sind
nach seinem freispruch im
amtsenthebungsverfahren sortiert
us-präsident ram zeugen aus die gegen
ihn ausgesagt haben
er berief mit sofortiger wirkung den us
botschafter bei der eu gordon scotland
ab außerdem entließ er den
sicherheitsexperten alexander widmen
beide hatten trump impeachment verfahren
schwer belastet die demokraten
kritisieren trump benehme sich als
stünde er über dem gesetz
in thailand hat ein soldat in einem
einkaufszentrum mit einem gewehr um sich
geschossen
mindestens 20 menschen wurden getötet
zahlreiche verletzt
die tat ereignete sich in der stadt
kurat im nordosten des landes etwa 260
kilometer von der hauptstadt bangkok
entfernt
laut polizeiangaben hat sich der täter
noch immer in dem einkaufszentrum
verschanzt und mehrere geiseln genommen
das tatmotiv ist noch unklar die
wetterprognosen sind ziemlich eindeutig
auf deutschland kommt ein schwerer sturm
zu mit gewittern starkregen und
orkanböen und zwar ab morgen vormittag
da soll es den norden treffen und
übermorgen dann den süden
wer unterwegs ist sollte besonders
aufpassen wird geraten anselm stern
die bahn rät vom bahnfahren ab von
morgen mittag bis dienstag drastische
anti sturm maßnahmen denn es drohen
kaputte oberleitungen und bäume auf den
gleisen heißt die reise könnte schwierig
werden tickets für sonntag montag oder
dienstag können auch flexible an anderen
tagen genutzt werden um die gültigkeit
verlängert man kann also mit diesen
tickets für sonntag montag oder dienstag
schon am heutigen samstag fahren und
auch noch eine woche später noch auf dem
atlantik doch der wintersturm sabine
wird sich auf den weg machen richtung
deutschland
sonntagvormittag sturmböen hier an der
nordsee das ganze verstärkt sich dann
letztendlich im laufe des tages und vor
allen dingen den abendstunden wird es
dann richtig heftig hier zb in
nordrhein-westfalen dunkle farbe das
bedeutet orkanböen bis nach sachsen
anhalt danken würde die mittelgebirge
nachts weiter und morgens zwischen
stuttgart und münchen sturm und
orkanböen in nordrhein westfalen fällt
am montag in fünf städten und
landkreisen der unterricht aus denn der
schulweg könnte gefährlich werden weil
windgeschwindigkeiten zwischen 100 und
140 kilometer in der stunde in einzelnen
böen haben wir natürlich auf jeden fall
brauchen wir die entwurzelt werden in
den wäldern aber auch in den straßen der
städte das wird sehr gefährlich
zusätzlich können sachen von den dächern
fallen oder ganze dächer abgedeckt
werden hier ganz im norden wurde heute
schon mal das zusammen gepackt was weg
fliegen könnte wenn morgen das orkantief
sabine nach deutschland kommt ja nicht
nur bei der bahn auch im flugverkehr
kann es zu einschränkungen kommen
online bleiben sie über sturmtief sabine
jederzeit auf dem laufenden
alle fragen und antworten im überblick
auf heute.de eine englische fliegerbombe
sollte entschärft werden eigentlich
routine aber dann war die explosion viel
stärker als erwartet in stahnsdorf in
brandenburg sind jetzt mehrere häuser
nicht mehr bewohnbar viele scheiben
gingen zu bruch
dächer wurden teilweise abgedeckt die
bombe war gestern bei baggerarbeiten
entdeckt worden
rund 6000 menschen mussten vorübergehend
ihre wohnungen verlassen
ja wir sind beim sport und einer fast
märchenhaften
sprung geschichten arbeiten ja dieser
geschichte kann man den titel geben
stefan im glück denn für stefan lauer
ist ein sportlicher traum in erfüllung
gegangen der 28 jährige vom sc willingen
gewinnt in seinem heimatort zum ersten
mal ein weltcup skispringen ein drehbuch
reifer triumph und einer der sich schon
früh angedeutet stephan leyhe bereits
erst danach der auf heute verschoben
qualifikation doch das beste kommt erst
noch 139,5 meter im ersten durchgang
bedeuten zunächst platz zwei mit seinem
spruch auf 144 5 meter im zweiten
durchgang fliegt der nahe der
mühlenkopfschanze geborene laie dann der
konkurrenz davon
sein erster einzel sieg bei einem
weltcupspringen ausgerechnet in der
heimat
dahinter der norweger marius lind weg
vor dem drittplatzierten polen kamil
stoch karl geiger wird fünfter an einem
tag an dem stephan leyhe alles in den
schatten stellt viktoria rebensburg hat
schon reichlich erfahrung mit
weltcupsiegen aber der neunzehnte ist
doch ein ganz besonderer zum ersten mal
gewinnt sie eine abfahrt und das auch
noch in garmisch partenkirchen eine
woche nach dem triumph von thomas
dreesen
auf die frage ob es der schönste moment
in ihrem skifahrer leben sei weiß
viktoria rebensburg keine antwort
überglücklich ist sie übermannt von
ihrem ersten großen triumph in einer
abfahrt
die hätte man besser erträumen können ja
mein erster abfahrtssieg daheim garmisch
mit family freunde fanclubs anhalter
einige da ja das ist natürlich
hammermäßig hammermäßig ist die fahrt
auf der kandahar piste von anfang an auf
dieser schwierigen strecke führt die
tour rebensburg früh schon zu neuen
bestzeiten und im ziel kann die 30
jährige ihren 19 weltcup sieg feiern
mit großem rückstand folgen abgeschlagen
die italienerin viele recovery ohne und
sk aus tschechien
das schlussbild ist heute durchaus
passend denn endlich einmal hat viktoria
rebensburg auch in einer abfahrt ihrem
vornamen alle ehre gemacht
laura siegemund sichert dem tennis
fedcup team der damen vorzeitig die
qualifikation für das finalturnier sie
holt mit ihrem zweiten einzelsieg in
florianopolis den notwendigen dritten
punkt gegen brasilien für werder bremen
und trainer florian co fällt wird die
lage in der fußball-bundesliga immer
bedrohlicher nach dem pokaltriumph gegen
dortmund heute wieder eine
heimniederlage gegen den aufsteiger
union berlin
die profis aus der hauptstadt gewinnen
an der weser mit 2 zu 0 mainz 05
triumphiert dagegen in berlin drei zu
eins durch drei kreisen treffer auch
paderborn punktet eins zu eins auf
schalke freiburg gegen hoffenheim 1 zu 0
und wolfsburg gegen düsseldorf eins zu
eins das abendspiel bestreiten
leverkusen und dortmund gestern der 15 0
heimsieg von frankfurt gegen augsburg
morgen das topspiel bayern gegen leipzig
und gladbach gegen köln vor von den
sechs ganz oben hat nur schalke sein 21
spiel hinter sich und überholt erstmal
leverkusen frankfurt springt in die
obere hälfte unten rutscht härter auf 14
mainz jetzt mit vier punkten vorsprung
auf die abstiegszone
wer dahinter düsseldorf nun vorletzter
und aufsteiger paderborn ist dicht dran
um 23 uhr ein spannendes sportstudio
ausführlich mit leverkusen gegen
dortmund und dhb vize bob hanning nach
der umstrittenen entlassung des handball
bundestrainers christian prokop wird ein
langer abend in bonn sowie sozusagen
genau was zum wetter das wird wie gesagt
stürmisch und gunther tiersch sagt in
gleich wann der orkan zu ihnen kommt das
heute journal mit claus kleber kommt
jedenfalls um 23 uhr 25 also kurz vor
halb zwölf wir sind für heute am ende
danken für ihr interesse und wünschen
einen ruhigen samstagabend morgen sind
wir dann wieder da um punkt 19 uhr
tschüss
[Musik]
meine liebe zuschauer morgen wird es
ziemlich stürmisch bei uns und abends
kommen die orkanböen dazu der sturm
liegt also morgen vormittag schon mal
über der nordsee erste stürmische böen
das ganze wird sich dann intensivieren
der sturm zieht weiter über die mitte
deutschlands vor allen dingen in den
nachtstunden mit sturm und orkanböen
am montagmorgen dann zwischen münchen
und stuttgart und montagnachmittag wird
sich der sturm dann langsam wieder
abschwächen heute nacht ruhiges wetter
ein bisschen regen hier im nordwesten
und der wind legt etwas zu im norden
weht aus südwest aber es ist noch nicht
stürmisch minus fünf grad sind an den
alpen plus sieben grad hier am
niederrhein und morgen wird es dann noch
milder als heute mit diesem starken wind
es sind acht bis vierzehn am oberrhein
auf 16 grad und weitere regenschauer
ziehen ins landesinnere mit diesem
starken wind zum teil dann am nachmittag
und abend heftige schauer
während es im osten und süden noch ganz
freundlich ist der sturm selbst beginnt
über der nordsee dann morgen vormittag
erste stürmische böen
er wird sich dann intensivieren im laufe
des nachmittags abends haben wir dann
die ersten orkanböen hier im westen und
nordwesten zu erwarten und um
mitternacht dann schwer in nordrhein
westfalen aber auch in sachsen sturm und
orkanböen
auch im schwarzwald montagmorgen dann
erreicht der sturm auch die gebiete
stuttgart und münchen
und wie gesagt dann am nachmittag
sozusagen wird sich der sturm vom westen
wieder etwas abschwächen
es bleibt dann allerdings finde ich bei
uns in deutschland also auch in der
nacht zum dienstag neuer sturm noch mal
über süddeutschland danach ist es kühler
mit schnee und regenschauern
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut